ja durch den klimawandel bleibt uns
jetzt eben nur noch wenige jahre zeit um
den kollaps die vernichtung unserer
lebensgrundlagen und damit auch
weltweite hungersnöte auch hier in
deutschland in der zukunft zu verhindern
und gleichzeitig können wir ganz
deutlich sehen dass unsere regierung
nicht das notwendige tut und das zu
verhindern und deswegen braucht es eben
friedlichen widerstand aus der
bevölkerung um das noch zu verhindern
dass unsere lebensgrundlagen
unwiederbringlich vernichtet werden
ich würde sagen bevor wir debattieren
wollen wir einmal hören was die leute
auf der straße dazu sagen
geweckt
doch schon sicher
die magd sie wissen ob die straße
geklebt und wie nett wie nett und wie
komme ich jetzt zum nächsten job aber
ich darf rechts vom fahne
ich wünsche ihnen normal dass wenn ein
krankenwagen wenn sie selbst betroffen
sind im krankenwagen sitzen und dadurch
kaum irgendwo zufrieden das ist ein
schöner effekt habe da sich entspannt
bin ich schon nach vorne ja
frau keller dessen teilweise krasse
reaktion ich hätte auch ein video
gesehen herr werner was ich sehr daneben
fand wo sie korrekt wurden von einem
autofahrer können sie denn die reaktion
verstehen außerhalb jetzt der ohrfeige
ich glaube gewalt empfindet hier niemand
am tisch als lösung gewalt ist niemals
eine lösung aber genau genommen ist das
auch gewollt was was er mit seinen
kollegen macht dort nämlich einen
eingriff in den straßenverkehr und das
ist eine nötigung alle autofahrer das
heißt sie wie hindern im endeffekt
menschen daran zur arbeit zu fahren sie
hindern krankenwagen sie hinter den
eltern daran irgendwie ihre kinder
abzuholen es sind auch schon leute haben
sich verletzt weil sie auf ihren
ölverschmierten was sie mit öl
verschmiert haben ist eine radfahrerin
gestürzt und hat sich verletzt ich halte
das ehrlich gesagt bei allem respekt für
politisches engagement
sehe ich keine begründung warum sie das
recht haben sollten im endeffekt
versagen wir mal ganz normale bürger in
ihren protest einzubeziehen oder ihnen
aufzunötigen dass sie dass sie den
straßenverkehr behindern ich kann
absolut verstehen wenn autofahrer sagen
sorry ich habe einen job ja ich muss
meinen lebensunterhalt selber verdienen
und und ich möchte jetzt gerne zu meiner
arbeit fahren und sie sind ja auch nicht
in der wie sein sie haben auch nicht das
recht der menschen vorzuschreiben ob sie
jetzt hier noch auto fahren dürfen oder
nicht ich würde mich einfach
grundsätzlich
gegen die these wehren dass es nötig ist
andere menschen zu nötigen nur damit sie
politisch gehör finden da haben wir doch
in einer demokratie haben wir doch
andere mittel zur verfügung und die
stehen ihnen zur verfügung wie jedem
anderen auch und da finde ich nicht dass
sie das recht haben im prinzip gewalt
anzuwenden gegenüber völlig unschuldigen
bürgern
das was wir da machen das findet ja vor
dem hintergrund statt dass wir einen
absoluten
lebensbedrohlichen notfall haben dass
sie ihre behauptung erst das ist das ist
so wie wir die realität beschreiben
können dass wenn wir jetzt nicht in den
schnee jahren dieses problem lösen und
die erhitzung stoppen dann werden wir
unsere lebensgrundlagen
unwiederbringlich verlieren das bedeutet
milliarden von menschen die ihre heimat
verlieren das bedeutet dass erst mal für
die menschen hier alles teurer wird dass
die menschen die hier erstmal die
weniger haben dann am meisten darunter
leiden wenn das es immer schlimmer wird
und dabei ist ja eigentlich auch ihr
anliegen ja das ist für die menschen
besser ist aber wir wissen das ist
erwiesen dass es immer schlimmer werden
wird dass es immer mehr
hungerkatastrophen geben wird das ist
immer mehr ernteausfälle geben wird bis
2030 wird die maisernte und 25 prozent
weltweit einbrechen laut nasa ich dann
ist das ist denn das ist der hintergrund
und uns vor diesem hintergrund ist auch
diese diese aktion zu betrachten das ist
das mir am das mildeste mir zur
verfügung stehende mittel um die
regierung noch zum handeln zu bewegen
sie haben andere maßnahmen angesprochen
ich kann nicht mehr guten gewissens eine
demo organisieren wenn ich weiß dass
selbst wenn ich 1,3 1,4 millionen
menschen mitnehmen auf die strasse
nehmen kann um zu demonstrieren dass die
bundesregierung dort was
verfassungswidriges macht wie das sollte
eigentlich deswegen kann ich das nicht
ein bisschen kann ich leider durch das
guten gewissens machen wenn ich weiß
dass das nicht effektiv ist das ist
nämlich nicht dahin lassen sie wollen
die menschen sie ob sie wollen solange
erpressen bis die menschen einfach tun
was sie sagen und dass das ist eine
nötigung das ist ehrlich gesagt ist das
fast totalitär was sie da fordern
gefährlicher eingriff in den
straßenverkehr und vieles andere mehr es
kann in diesem fall mit dem öl natürlich
eine körperverletzung sein oder oder
oder und er werner sie hatten ja in
ihrem ersten beitrag gesagt dass es in
der gesellschaft natürlich regeln gibt
dass man sich anschnallt dass man sich
vielleicht impfen muss oder wie auch
immer
wir müssen nicht alle alle gesetze die
es in deutschland gibt gut oder gar
richtig finden aber es muss natürlich
einen gesellschaftlichen konsens geben
dass die gesetze die von einer mehrheit
in der demokratie beschlossen worden
sind ich gehöre jetzt selbst zu einer
oppositionsfraktion und wer hat mich da
in der regel nicht durchsetzen können
aber die gesetze gelten und es gibt ein
gewaltmonopol des staates der setzt
diese gesetze durch wenn man sich
ungerecht behandelt fühlt dann kann man
vor gericht ziehen es gibt also viele
möglichkeiten man kann sich politisch
engagieren man kann für andere
mehrheiten kämpfen wenn man andere
genügend überzeugt aber diese
spielregeln verdi auf kündigt der es
stellt sich natürlich dann auch
außerhalb der gesellschaft das muss man
schon sagen und vorteile das was sie
angesprochen haben das ist ihr empfinden
ja es ist ebenso menschen sind
unterschiedlich an unterschiedliche
prioritäten und werden unterschiedliche
dinge als ganz besonders wichtig ansehen
sie werden im zweifel wenn ich mir ihr
engagement anschauen immer kinder in den
mittelpunkt des engagement ausrichten
das kann man mit sehr guten gründen
machen und wieder andere haben andere
schwerpunkte deswegen sich da auf einen
grundkonsens zu einigen ich glaube das
ist entscheidend wenn das nicht gelingt
dann hat es etwas totalitäres ich glaube
man muss es als das benennen das ist
eine frage zwischendurch ein herr ein
schritt würden sie auch also wie stehen
sie dazu zu erwehren dass engagement b
würden sie auch mitmachen ich würde in
keiner demonstrations- vor mitmachen die
strafrechts relevant werde als politiker
schon gleich gar nicht übrigens weil die
auch ein bisschen trennen müssen meine
rolle ist ja im bundestag zu arbeiten
ihre rolle ist aktives zu sein was ich
respektiere ich will aber in einem
zustimmen wenn wir die klimakrise nicht
in den griff kriegen dann wird unsere
freiheit massiv eingeschränkt werden das
ist auch das bundesverfassungsgericht
und was wir hatten und deswegen ist es
richtig auch darauf hinzuweisen auch in
drastischen form aber bitte im rahmen
des rechtsstaats wir hatten auch in
unserer tradition als bundesrepublik
immer wieder protestformen die etwas
unkonventionell waren in den 60er jahren
siebziger jahren aber wir müssen
aufpassen dass wir nicht gewisse normen
verlassen die dann eben auch zu
gegenreaktionen führen die der sache gar
nicht helfen würden das ist das was wir
sehen ja wenn etwas wirklich
verfassungswidrig ist dann gibt es eine
entsprechende rechtsprechung die dann
anschließend auch umgesetzt wird also
wenige wochen später hat der deutsche
bundestag ein neues klimaschutzgesetz
verabschiedet
das ist was sie sagen dass für normale
politische anliegen ist das natürlich
richtig und wichtig dass ich mich dann
erstmal an die an die strukturen halten
die prozesse halt und das ist ja auch
passiert bei dem thema seit jahrzehnten
laufen diese prozesse und seit
jahrzehnten wird es immer schlimmer und
jetzt stehen wir eben kurz kurz vor der
krippe und wir können jetzt denn dass
alle verstehen sind schon so daran
erinnern dann werden wir gesagt hat dass
die das in diesem jahr in dem wir jetzt
leben dass dann kein baum mehr steht in
deutschland ich bin schon so alt dass
ich noch weiß dass man mir erzählt hat
dass das ozonloch die ganze erde quasi
und kreisen wohnungen der klima schafft
und und sehr eindeutig nein nein aber
ich will ihnen nur sagen wir haben über
die frage wie sich die umwelt verändern
wird und was alles ganz schlimm werden
wird haben wir schon verschiedene kaspar
katastrophenszenarien in den letzten
jahrzehnten gehört die wenigsten davon
sind eingetreten und deswegen kann ich
mich ehrlich gesagt auch an ihrer minder
meinung nicht beteiligen das jetzt quasi
akut eine derartige bedrohung ist dass
sie glauben sie müssten die
rechtsstaatlichen mitteln verlassen und
irgendeine politik zu erzwingen sorry
sollen notstand haben wir nicht vor ein
paar tagen hat die selbst die un davon
gesprochen dass wir gerade auf dem weg
sind zu dem kompletten
gesellschaftlichen kollaps
das ist eher das ist dass das die un
veröffentlicht
und das wahrscheinlich in organisation
und daher als auf dem auf dem wir unser
berlin demokratische liga geben will die
genannten zu sprechen ich weiß auch
schon weiterhin auch zurück dass das wir
uns außerhalb des des rechtsstaates
bewegende leisten zivilen widerstand er
ist friedlich der ist zivil insofern
dass ich da bleibe ich gehe ja nicht weg
wenn ich die pipeline abdrehen bleibe
ich da wenn ich auf der straße bin gebe
ich der polizei gerne meine aussage ja
ich mache das ich stehe dazu dass ich
das mache und dabei ist ich sehe mich
auch nicht sehr hoch es ist total neben
der welt hat und weil als dieser
rechtsstaat den wir ja erhalten wollen
und es ist vollkommen klar dass wenn wir
das nicht schaffen
dann ist das unwiederbringlich vorbei
das ist ja auch eine wahrscheinlichkeit
geschichte wenn natürlich können wir
nicht in die glaskugel blicken aber wenn
das klima kippt und wir sind auf dem weg
dahinter zeigt das zeigt die
wissenschaft ganz deutlich auch dann
haben wir für die nächsten tausenden von
jahren lebensfeindlichen bedingungen für
die menschheit wo wir kein essen mehr
anbauen können wo es zu wenig lebensraum
gibt wie sollen wir dann hier noch
gemeinschaftlich leben wie soll dann der
rechtsstaat aufrecht erhalten werden da
habe ich persönlich große angst vor
deswegen mache ich das hinter sich ist
ich würde mich natürlich auch lieber in
meiner komfortzone bewegen und sachen
machen die die nicht so konfrontativ
sind und nicht so in das menschen in das
leben entscheiden und das macht mir
persönlich keinen spaß aber ich sehe
keinen anderen keinen anderen weg mehr
handy sei in dieser notlage und das
würde hier auch ganz wieder deutlich
dass das diese dass dieser klima notfall
in dem wir uns befinden gesellschaftlich
nicht anerkannt ist das stift paar
jahren fordern sie noch in der cdu
klimaneutralität 2045 sein fordern jetzt
klimaneutralität
2050 sie fordern klimaneutralität 2045
um das 1,5 grad ziel zu erreichen jetzt
erreichen wir aber 1,5 grad vor 2030
wie ist das zu erklären wie kann ich das
als bürger dieses staates der diesen
staat erhalten möchte den rechtsstaat
einfach so hinnehmen ohne dagegen
widerstand zu leisten wenn die anderen
gängigen methoden ausgeschöpft und ich
weiß keinen anderen weg und deswegen
mache ich das eine frage noch dazu zu
ihrem 10 formen und warum sie das machen
man macht ja oft oder die presse auch
aber auch twitter und co und bürger und
auch ich wundere mich manchmal über die
letzte generation und diesen aktivismus
dadurch auch sagen warum viele aus den
gruppen kommen selber aus er vermögenden
verhältnissen auch tonnen
klimaaktivisten die bekanntesten
beispiele sind dieser neubauer und carla
reemtsma die auch sehr wohl am
verhältnissen kommen die frage die ich
mir nicht mein mann manchmal stelle
können sie denn das vorurteil vielleicht
ich bezeichne es jemals forscher
verstehen dass viele auch sagen sie sind
weltfremd wenn sie sich auf die straße
setzen und anderen leuten die halt viel
geld arbeiten müssen wir gerade gehört
jemand kommen nicht zur arbeit
wahrscheinlich kriegt der ärger vom chef
wie nehmen sie denn diese argumente
gegen ihre bewegungen auf dass sie
vielleicht einfach ja dass es ihnen
vielleicht auch einfach zu gut geht und
andere sich gar nicht so sehr damit
beschäftigen können weil sie einfach für
ihr leben sorgen müssen ja das wird
jetzt wieder implizieren dass wir das
auf eine weise wie spaß macht mich da
mich dahin zu setzen mit dieser
kombination auszusetzen mir ist das
bewusst ich habe es auch tun zu können
da habe ich mir sowas neuen star weil
wir uns auch dieses privileg bewusst
dass ich das machen natürlich habe ich
nur einbildung genießen dürfen in diesem
land und
das ist für mich aber umso mehr ansporn
was zu tun ist sagt ja ich sehe haben
entfällt das ich sehe kein anderes
mittel als
diese art von widerstand zu leisten der
nicht ignoriert werden kann
und natürlich ist das mit einigen kosten
verbunden mit aufwand wie sich manche
nicht leisten können land und den würde
ich auch nie persönlich einen vorwurf
machen aber ich lade ich rufe alle
menschen auf sich dem widerstand
anzuschließen die diese möglichkeit
haben weil wer soll das denn sonst
machen sollen dass die leute machen die
sowieso schon unfassbar schwierigkeiten
haben ihre rechnungen zu bezahlen
die menschen hören sie ja aufwendiger
stehen im auto es ist ja eher aus einer
komfortzone die haben sie ja gerade
selber bestätigt wir sind wirklich jetzt
als argument nicht nur als vorteil mehr
bezeichnen sie halten die menschen auf
verstehen sie dann vielleicht manchmal
das ärgernis das natürlich daraus rührt
ich kann den ärger vollkommen verstehen
er macht das wie schon gesagt das ist
etwas das ich abwäge ist eine ethische
abwägung für mich und es fällt mir nicht
leicht und ich komme trotzdem zu dem
schluss dass zu machen diese menschen da
so in ihrem alltag zu stören und es ist
vollkommen verständlich dass sie darüber
würden sind ja aber glauben sie allen
ernstes dass sie damit ihre ziele
erreichen können
wir haben deutlich gesehen was mit den
straßen locken in berlin das druck
aufgebaut werden kann in einer art und
weise auf die regierung die wir sonst
nicht erzielen würden mit so wenig
menschen die wir haben wenn wir brauchen
eigentlich eine zivilgesellschaft die
das licht weiterhin nimmt was hier
passiert